thank you for coming it's been two years
since we've sat across from each other
didn't expect to have a second interview
with you I'm grateful that we're able to
um thank you so when we spoke before you
described what you believed were Hunter
Biden and the Biden families
effectively offenses against the United
States the ways that their business
practices that undermined U.S national
security but there was also an offense
against you what seemed like seemed like
fraud
um and now two years later we have I
think a pretty hard example of what that
looked like so if you wouldn't mind
explaining to us this is I think going
back to the spring and summer of 2017
Sino Hawk Holdings okay what was that so
Sino Hawk Holdings was a Delaware LLC
which was effectively a partnership
between uh the Biden family myself Rob
Walker and James gillier and a Chinese
large company called cefc which was
turned out to be effectively be the
capitalistic arm of you know president
she's one belt one road yes and so China
Hawk Holdings was the entity that
um chairman Yi who was the chairman of
CFC uh and an entity called Hudson West
4 owned 50 of cyanohawk Holdings and an
entity that represented the Biden family
myself James Gillian Rob Walker called
Oneida Holdings on the other 50 of that
entity show at the beginning of this
deal the Chinese were supposed to send
Sino Hawk money how much yeah so
actually I'm glad you asked the question
because a lot of discussion has been
about the 10 million dollars the Chinese
were supposed to fund into cyanohawk
Holdings five million dollars of that
was representing their 50 percent and
the 5 million dollars they would call it
a loan to the Biden family but
effectively it was a loan to Oneida
Holdings to represent the original
operating capital and that was just
operating Capital
um that Sino Hawk Holdings was set up to
effectively deploy billions of dollars
that CFC was claiming and rightfully
believable because they were doing it
around the world to invest via sign a
hawk in infrastructure projects
technology companies investment banks
financial institutions both here in the
U.S and around the world so this is the
limit liability company agreement of
Sino Hawk Holdings and it says here may
2017. what is this so that's actually a
very intense legal document that's
drafted in in details how Sino Hawk
Holdings will operate uh who are the
partners involved in the entity it
basically dictates how the business you
know who sits on the board of it who
will run it day to day I was the CEO of
cyanohawk Holdings and I was vested with
certain rights and authorities and stuff
like that and how you would distribute
profits to the partners and stuff so
very detailed document and a fully
executed it's important because you know
when I came out in October 2020 a lot of
people argued well you know that deal
never happened that deal 100 happened
that Santa Hawk document that you're
holding was fully executed both by Jim
Biden Hunter Biden myself James Gilly
Rob Walker and then on the Chinese side
Hudson West 4 executed the document so
it was a fully the operating business so
here's a very strange document and I
hope you can explain it this is a
limited liability company agreement of
byz Holdings LLC and this is from August
August 2nd of 2017 three months later
the reason this is strange is this
document is identical down to the serial
numbers on the bottom of the page to
this document the sign of Hawk Holdings
agreement except it's got a different
company name yeah what is this so um
interesting so that document is exactly
the same document as Sino Hawk Holdings
LLC and it appears that Hunter buying
Jim Biden and the Biden family literally
copied the same document down to typos
as you said the serial number and they
removed Oneida Holdings
which was the Delaware LLC that
represented Jim Biden Hunter Biden
myself Rob Walker and James gillier and
uh Hunter and his lawyer George mazier's
replaced it with Owasco which was Hunter
Biden's
Law Firm or business that he operated so
he effectively swapped out an entity
that he owned 20 percent of to a
business that he owned 100 percent of
which is fraud so why would he do that
um a lot of detail we don't you know
have I understand but basically at a
high level in July 2017 the Chinese CFC
had not funded the 10 million dollars I
was extremely frustrated the bidens
um
claimed or presented to be frustrated I
got calls from Jim Biden he was ready to
call the Chinese directly and and say
the buying families pulling out of a
deal all well documented in text
messages WhatsApp and emails and um I
didn't know this at the time but
apparently around that same time Hunter
Biden and his lawyers basically removed
Oneida
um put Owasco his law firm in that and
replace that in that document getting
prepared to basically divert that money
into uh byz Holdings so they were
shafting you without your knowledge it
sounds like yeah it's called fraud yeah
and this is I mean I don't see any other
explanation for this do you
uh I'm sure you can reach out to the
Biden family and get comment from them
um okay so this is just this alone
seems to me enough to Spur a criminal
investigation by the FBI into what
apparently is fraught
the FBI had the contents of the laptop
they've had it in four years now
um has there been an FBI investigation
into this and what's the what's the
outcome of it you know I'm not aware of
them focusing on those specific facts
everything that I've been preview or
briefed on is they're focusing on more
Legacy tax stuff fairer stuff they
should be looking into that but hunter
Biden has not been indicted for this uh
I'm not aware of that
um he ultimately if you actually want to
get into more detail they ultimately
um evolved from using byz Holdings to
then just going directly into an entity
called Hudson West 3 and that's where he
received the
um I think over five million dollars
across 2017 and 2018 of which he took a
portion and paid on a monthly basis uh
to his Uncle Jim Biden and I think Jim's
wife Sarah was involved so how much did
Hunter expect to make from his business
dealings with the Chinese so not only
Hunter I I wasn't interested they you
know they had to work on me for years to
sort of you know call it come off the
bench and get involved here in the
spring of 2017 I expected CFC was going
to deploy billions of dollars through
Sino Hawk and I was focused on taking
those billions of dollars and making a
return on it and I expected to make
hundreds of millions of dollars I think
the buy-ins probably thought they were
going to make billions of dollars
how much do you think hunter in the end
got from
this from diverting this money do you
think he received the money so he
definitely received the money I mean the
the bank statements have been made
public you know he received over five
million dollars and then I think an
incremental one million dollars uh in a
legal consulting fee to represent
um Patrick ho which is a story in itself
so this seems very cut and dried black
and white
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight